choisirez-vous de faire croire vos
enfants au Père Noël la question peut
vous paraître absurde pourtant sur Tik
Tok le hashtag Santa isentrill cumule
près de 20 millions de vues à l'heure où
j'enregistre cette vidéo et on y voit de
jeunes parents défendre le fait de ne
pas faire croire leurs enfants au Père
Noël pour leur éviter une expérience
traumatisante
en même temps je me demande si on peut
vraiment ne jamais mentir aux enfants il
y a bien des trucs sur lesquels on est
obligé de broder un petit peu non bon
écoute-moi bien si le Père Noël n'existe
pas c'est une figure imaginaire une
construction sociale comme beaucoup de
choses d'ailleurs le genre est une
construction sociale la monnaie est une
construction sociale écoute la société
elle-même est une construction sociale
d'accord bon allez maintenant on va lui
parce que c'est l'heure d'aller dormir
et l'heure du dodo ça c'est
ça c'est une vraie réalité intangible
bon moi je vais pas spécialement d'avis
sur le sujet mais ça me fait quand même
me poser une question pourquoi fait-on
croire les enfants au Père Noël
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur
sociologique j'espère que vous allez
bien en ces fêtes de fin d'année et on
est parti pour un petit épisode spécial
Noël l'année dernière j'avais déjà
répondu partiellement à cette question
du Père Noël grâce au travail de
Lévi-Strauss qui retraçait les origines
du Père Noël moderne et qui montrait que
derrière l'apparence de la nouveauté
dans les années 50 on pouvait trouver un
assemblage de nombreux rythes très
anciens qui se retrouvaient ainsi
bricoler reconfiguré par 5 réticisme
dans ce qui s'apparente à un rite de
passage qui organise la coupure entre
ceux qui savent et ceux qui ne savent
pas en gros le monde des enfants et le
monde des adultes mais aujourd'hui on va
étudier le Père Noël sous un angle plus
fonctionnaliste on va se demander quel
est sa fonction dans notre société et
pour ça on va s'appuyer sur celui qu'on
appelle le père de l'anthropologie
française à savoir Marcel Moos non ça
c'est Mickey Mouse je dis Marcel MOS
voilà on est parti
[Musique]
alors pour commencer il faut que je vous
présente rapidement Marcel Moos je vous
en ai déjà parlé quelquefois notamment
dans l'épisode 8 de sociologique mais je
me suis jamais vraiment attardé alors
que c'est vraiment une figure majeure
des sciences sociales il est né en 1872
il est mort en 19050 et c'est le neveu
d'Émile durkane ce qui va à se fortement
influencer sa vocation et sa carrière
alors le travail le plus connu de Mauss
c'est sans conteste son fameux essai sur
le don alors on dirait rarement le nom
complet mais le titre entier c'est essai
sur le don forme et raison de l'échange
dans les sociétés archaïques paru entre
1923 et 1924 dans l'année sociologique
qui est la revue fondée par Émile
Durkheim ce texte il est super important
parce que il se propose de définir une
base anthropologique commune à toutes
les sociétés humaines rien que ça pour
MOS c'est donc le rituel du don qui est
à la base des interactions humaines ce
rituel il est assez simple c'est l'idée
simplement que tout dont est
nécessairement suivi d'un contredon
selon des codes préétablis qui eux
peuvent varier d'une j'étais à l'autre
vivre en société c'est donc à prendre à
donner mais c'est aussi à prendre à
recevoir et à donner en retour sa forme
ce qu'on appelle le triptyque du donner
recevoir rendre pour montrer
l'importance du don Mosa donc étudié
c'est qu'il appelle les sociétés
archaïques pour mettre en évidence la
nature du lien qui permet à ces sociétés
d'exister alors je mets des très gros
guillemets sur le terme société
archaïque mais je vais pas m'étendre
dessus ici vous pouvez aller voir ma
vidéo sur Ladis rose dans Game of
Thrones si vous voulez en savoir plus
sur les petits problèmes de terminologie
de ces premiers travaux anthropologiques
pour MOS le don est donc ce qu'il
appelle un fait social total
si vous en souvenez bien on avait déjà
parlé de cette notion dont mon épisode
sur la voiture dans cet ouvrage il
décrivent l'automobile comme un fait
social total alors un fait social total
c'est une expression qu'on doit au
sociologue Marcel moze dont j'avais déjà
parlé dans ma précédente vidéo alors lui
il s'en servait pour parler du don mais
c'est à peu près la même idée ici l'idée
du fait social total c'est qu'on est ici
face à un élément qui donne une
signification globale à toute une
réalité sociale il faut il faut que tu
arrêtes de jouer avec mon micro l'idée
c'est que le don a des implications sur
l'ensemble du fonctionnement de la
société et qu'à travers lui on voit en
filigrane toutes les coutumes et toutes
les institutions de la société qu'elles
soient aussi bien religieuses juridique
que morale politique et familial bref
c'est toute la société qui se conforme
au fameux triptyque du données recevoir
rendre Maud veut notamment montrer que
l'échange n'est absolument pas une
opération marchande désincarner et
rationnelle comme peuvent le concevoir
les économistes mais qu'il est au
contraire une matérialisation des
relations sociales
le donateur oblige le donataire à
rentrer dans l'échange et le soumet à
une obligation sociale de rendre qui
fonde les relations sociales en même
temps qu'elle les pacifique et il montre
notamment que derrière les pratiques
apparentes de générosité de gratuité et
de liberté se cache en fait un cadre
très strict de règles et de code sociaux
le refus de données de recevoir ou de
rendre en fait c'est comme une rupture
des rapports sociaux comme il le note
lui-même refusait de donner négliger
d'inviter comme refuser de prendre et
qui vaut à déclarer la guerre c'est
refuser l'Alliance et la communion et
c'est vrai que pour montrer qu'on ne
veut pas rentrer dans une interaction
sociale c'est tout à fait efficace de
refuser de recevoir un cadeau
du coup puisque le don oblige il peut
aussi être à la source de liens de
domination ne pas pouvoir rendre à la
hauteur de ce qu'on a reçu c'est aussi
se maintenir dans une position
d'infériorité vis-à-vis du donateur
c'est une mécanique qu'on voit par
exemple s'instaurer dans le film Fifty
Shades of grey quand le personnage est
ponyme essaye d'assurer son emprise sur
la jeune Anastasia il contrôle petit à
petit sa vie ce qu'elle mange ou elle va
qui elle voit mais on peut remarquer que
tout commence par des cadeaux onéreux à
savoir ici une voiture et un ordinateur
en lui faisant ses cadeaux d'une valeur
bien supérieure est-ce qu'elle pourra
jamais lui rendre le milliardaire
affirme ainsi SAS domination sur Anna et
la maintient dans une position
d'infériorité et c'est d'ailleurs ce
phénomène de don comme un outil de
domination qui va particulièrement
intéresser Marcel Moos car il consacre
une bonne partie de son livre à ce qu'il
appelle les formes agonistiques du don
c'est à dire du don vu comme un combat
pour étudier ça il va se pencher sur les
travaux de deux votre père fondateur de
l'anthropologie qui avait étudié
respectivement le rituel des potelets
sur la côte ouest de l'Amérique du Nord
et le phénomène de la Kula dans les îles
trop brillants de l'océan Pacifique et
personnellement je suis hyper content
d’aborder enfin ce sujet sur la chaîne
parce que j'adore le mot potelack non
mais c'est vrai on dirait une espèce de
grosse plâtre de porridge qu'on
viendrait se faire splater par terre là
alors que pas du tout en fait s'il ne
vous est pas familier le mot potelatch
veut simplement dire nourrir dans la
langue des shinos que du nord-ouest de
l'Amérique du Nord chez eux le potelatch
est une sorte de rituel basée sur le don
contre don on a une personne qui offre à
une autre un objet en fonction de
l'importance qu'elle accorde à cet objet
une importance qui est évaluée
personnellement mais bon en général il
faut que ce soit du en cadeau de grande
valeur genre le beau cadeau et l'autre
personne lui offrira en retour un objet
dont l'importance sera estimé comme
équivalente et on rentre alors dans une
espèce de guerre des richesses en gros
c'est à celui qui offrira le plus c'est
une véritable orgie de dons le plus
souvent ça donne lieu à même des
destructions d'objets de valeur juste
pour pouvoir faire l'étalage de sa
richesse en fait c'est seulement les
chefs qui s'échangent des cadeaux mais
ils impliquent bien toute leur tribus
avec eux dans ce type d'échanges c'est
l'honneur des participants et leur
groupe d'appartenance qui est en jeu
ainsi que leur rang même dans la société
mais les populations chez nous qui ne
sont pas les seuls à avoir ce type de
rituel et marcelmos va mettre en
évidence des points communs entre cette
pratique du potelatch au nord-ouest
américain avec le phénomène de la Kula
c'est à dire les échanges de colliers de
bracelets dans des sociétés du nord-est
de la Nouvelle-Guinée qui ont été
étudiés par miniowski le but principal
de ces échanges c'est encore une fois
pas l'accumulation de richesse mais
c'est plutôt la conquête et la
confirmation du prestige et de l'honneur
mais le pote là chez la couleur on les
confond parfois parce qu'en fait Marcel
Moos va se proposer d'utiliser le terme
potelatch comme concept anthropologique
pour définir les échanges de type
agonistique en général du coup quand on
utilise le terme potelatch en
anthropologie on ne désigne pas
seulement les cérémonies chez nous
étudiées par Franck boaze mais toutes
ces cérémonies où l'on s'échange
principalement pour garder son statut et
son honneur et clairement on ne peut pas
comprendre ces cérémonies si on les
étudie sous l'angle des échanges
marchands d'aujourd'hui et sans
comprendre leur fonction évidemment
sociale d'ailleurs petite parenthèse
mais c'est notamment pour ça que les
premiers colons américains ont pu
considérablement spolier les indigènes
qui pratiquaient le potlatch parce que
ces derniers échanger leur or contre des
bibelots sans valeur de la part des
occidentaux les indien habitués à ces
échanges symboliques croyez à la valeur
potelatch de ces échanges en gros il
pensait que les trocs étaient équilibrés
alors que clairement les Occidentaux ils
étaient juste là pour profiter et leur
offrait trois merde pour faire genre et
on sait que quand on fait se rencontrer
les intentions purement marchandes sur
une logique essentiellement sociale et
ben en général ça fait pas bon ménage
pour réveiller par cœur non c'est
fou et tout autour de nous et pas
uniquement sous nos pieds Lina avis le
savent et ils sont prêts à se battre et
à le défendre si vous voulez partager ce
monde avec eux il faut que vous
appreniez à les comprendre
en conclusion de son essai Marcel Moos
invite donc le lecteur à analyser
l'effet économique des sociétés modernes
de manière à voir les logiques sociales
qui les sous tendent d'ailleurs Alain
cahier rendra hommage à cet appel
anti-utilitariste de Marcel Moos quand
ils fondera en 1981 la revue du
mouvement anti-utilitariste en sciences
sociales vous avez compris parce que du
coup les lettres ça fait MOS que comme
Marcel Moos du coup c'est
c'est rigolo
d'ailleurs pour revenir à Noël des
économistes se sont déjà amusés analysés
les échanges de cadeaux de Noël d'un
point de vue uniquement utilitariste et
ils ont donc conclu que c'est un
non-sens parfaitement
inefficace car il y a aucune chance
qu'on vous fasse un cadeau qui vous
ferait au moins autant plaisir que si on
vous avait offert directement l'argent
pour vous acheter ce que vous voulez
monsieur fille avait d'ailleurs fait une
vidéo sur le sujet et je vous invite à
aller la voir si ça vous intéresse mais
évidemment tout ça c'est sans compter
sur la fonction éminemment sociale de
l'échange de cadeaux qui ne peut se
mesurer d'un point de vue utilitariste
bref mais maintenant que je vous ai
parlé de tout ça est-ce qu'on va enfin
en arriver au sujet de notre vidéo
pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait croire aux
enfants que leurs cadeaux sont arrivés
par l'entremise d'un vieux barbu
ventripotent qui arrive à passer par la
cheminée sans se retrouver couvert
dessus et bien si vous avez compris tout
ce que je vous ai expliqué vous avez
compris que le don c'est loin d'être
juste un acte de générosité mais qu'il
peut aussi être le support de la
domination et générer de la gêne quand
il est déséquilibré et c'était problème
qui se posent forcément lors d'un rituel
d'échange de dons comme Noël et je suis
sûr que vous avez déjà vécu cette
situation un peu hypocrite tu sais où
tout le monde se dit bon cette année on
se battre cadeau ok mais que tu sais
pertinemment qu'il y a deux connards qui
vont pas suivre la règle et donc petit à
petit tout le monde commence à acheter
quand même quelques merdes et qu'en fait
en entourent on se retrouve avec un
sapin qui dégueule de babioles
probablement confectionné par des Wiggs
avec un bilan carbone aussi positif que
que le nombre de like en dessous de
cette vidéo simplement parce que
personne ne voulait perdre la face en
étant le seul à ne pas offrir de cadeau
mais bon si on sait résigner à tout ça
en tant qu'adulte et ben c'est quand
même quelque chose dont on essaierait de
préserver les enfants selon cette vision
fonctionnaliste le Père Noël aurait donc
le gros avantage de permettre aux
enfants de recevoir des dons tout en les
exonérant de la nécessité de faire un
contre don puisque le Père Noël est une
espèce d'entité magique qui ne rentre
pas dans le triptyque du données
recevoir rendre bon si il y a toujours
ce truc de pour avoir ses cadeaux il
faut bien se comporter nanana mais on
est clairement pas dans le contredon
traditionnel avec des objets de même
valeur comme le note pierre merkley dans
sa chronique pour le monde faire croire
au père nouvelle avec autant
d'acharnement c'est chercher à masquer
les donateurs réels pour libérer
symboliquement les enfants de la dette
impossible à rembourser qu'ils ont à
l'égard de leurs parents d'ailleurs une
bonne preuve de ça c'est que à partir du
moment où on ne croit plus au Père Noël
on devient généralement juste ici de
devoir faire à son tour des cadeaux de
Noël à ses parents et à ses frères et
soeurs certains enfants sont d'ailleurs
très conscients de ça parce que dans les
entretiens qui ont été faits sur le
sujet plusieurs personnes à vous avoir
fait semblant de toujours croire au Père
Noël de peur de ne plus recevoir de
cadeaux ou pour ne pas avoir en fer aux
autres pour conclure faisons donc
attention avant de jeter immédiatement
le Père Noël avec l'eau du mensonge
parental ce serait bête de dire la
vérité aux enfants dans le but de leur
éviter le traumatisme du mensonge pour
juste derrière les traumatisés quand
même avec le poids d'une dette
impossible à combler vis-à-vis des
adultes non sérieux en plus il y a déjà
la réforme des retraites pour ça donc
cet épisode de socio Quick est
maintenant terminé j'espère qu'il vous
aura plu n'hésitez pas à partager autour
de vous sur les réseaux sociaux à mettre
un pouce vers le haut si vous voulez
aller plus loin je vous invite à vous
plonger dans le petit livre de Baptiste
coulemont et Pierre Merley pourquoi les
top models ne sourient pas chronique
sociologique c'est un petit recueil de
toutes les chroniques qu'ils ont écrit
pour le monde et justement il y en a une
sur la croyance au Père Noël je vous
mettrai d'ailleurs dans la description
le lien vers l'article du Monde et aussi
vers le blog de Pierre Berkeley dans
lequel il a fait une version longue de
cet article si ça vous intéresse d'aller
plus loin en attendant je vous souhaite
d'excellentes fêtes de fin d'année on va
se retrouver normalement avant la fin de
l'année pour quelques petites vidéos
bilans je vous fais de gros bisous et à
très vite Ciao
[Musique]